[♪]
JUDGE JEANINE: PRESIDENT TRUMP
SAID IT EARLIER THIS EVENING.
THE DWRAD YOU’LL REOPENING OF
AMERICA IS ALREADY UNDER WAY.
JOINING ME, ONE OF THE NEWEST
MEMBERS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION TEAM.
KAYLEIGH MCENANY.
THE PRESIDENT TALKED ABOUT THE
GRADUAL REOPENING AND TALKED
ABOUT TECH AS AND VERMONT.
WHY THOSE TWO AND WHAT CAN WE
EXPECT AFTER THAT?
>> THE PRESIDENT SET THE
PARAMETERS TO REOPEN THE
COUNTRY.
THIS IS IN LINE WITH MEDICAL
EXPERTS.
I HAVE BEEN IN THE TASK FORCE
MEETINGS.
I SAW THEM COUPLE THESE
GUIDELINES.
AS HE SAID FOR WEEKS.
I CAN DO TWO THING AT ONCE.
I CAN KEEP THE HEALTH AND
WELL-BEING OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE FIRST AND REOPEN THE
ECONOMY.
CONGRESS IS TAKING STEPS,
FLORIDA IS TAKING STEPS.
THEY ARE DOING SO AS THE
GOVERNORS HAVE DECIDED.
JUDGE JEANINE: GOVERNOR CUOMO IS
SAYING WE NEED MONEY FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, WE NEED MORE
FROM THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
WHAT IS THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
GOING TO DO IN TERMS OF
INDIVIDUAL STATES LIKE NEW YORK.
>> LET’S GO TO THE CONSTITUTION
AND THE WAY GOVERNING WORKS AND
THE STATES ARE SUPPOSED TO TAKE
THE LEAD ON HAVING VENTILATORS
AND TESTING AND SUPPLIES.
BUT DESPITE THE FACT IT’S THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF STATES, THIS
PRESIDENT HAS STEPPED UP.
THIS PRESIDENT WHEN NEW YORK WAS
SAYING WE NEED 40,000
VENTILATORS, 30,000 VENTILATORS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP SENT TONS OF
VENTILATORS.
SO MANY THAT NEW YORK IS SAYING
WE DON’T NEED THESE, AND THEY
ARE SENDING THEM TO OTHER STATES
AS WASHINGTON HAS DONE AND
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS STEPPED UP
EVEN THOUGH IT’S THE STATES’
RESPONSIBILITY TO STOCKPILE.
JUDGE JEANINE: BY BRINGING THE
NAVAL SHIPS IN AND DREDGING ITS
WAY INTO THE PIER IN NEW YORK.
YET THOSE ARE EMPTY.
ARE SOME OF THESE GOVERNORS
BEING A LITTLE JOE DRAMATIC IN
TERMS OF WHAT THEY WANT FROM THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT?
>> THERE HAVE BEEN A LOT OF
REQUESTS AND THIS PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN STRATEGIC IN WHAT THE NEED
IS.
NOT THE ASKS.
BUT THE NEED.
WE BE SAY NOT A SINGLE AMERICAN
HAS DIED FOR LACK OF A
VENTILATOR.
THAT’S BECAUSE OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THIS IS THE GREATEST
MOBILIZATION SINCE WORLD WAR II.
THE GREATEST MOBILIZATION OF
AMERICAN SOCIETY.
WHAT THIS PRESIDENT HAS DONE IN
TESTING IS THE NEW THING THE
MEDIA IS TALKING ABOUT.
TWO TIMES MORE THAN ANY COUNTRY
ON THE FACE OF THIS EARTH.
IT’S EXTRAORDINARY.
>> LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
THERE IS DIFFERENT TEST.
THERE IS A TESTING TO DETERMINE
WHETHER YOU HAVE THE VIRUS.
THEN THERE IS THE TEST TO
DETERMINE WHETHER YOU HAVE THE
ANTIBODY WHICH APPARENTLY IS
EVEN MORE AVAILABLE.
SO WHICH TEST SHOULD PEOPLE BE
TAKING?
>> SO THE EXPERTS HAVE
DISTINGUISHED BETWEEN THE TWO.
THE DIAGNOSTIC TEST WAS THE
FIRST PHASE OF THE TESTING.
IF YOU ARE SYMPTOMATIC YOU WANT
TO GET THAT TEST.
THE ANTIBODY TEST WHICH HAS BEEN
FAST TRACKED THROUGH THE FDA.
THIS IS A GAME CHANGER.
WE CAN SEE WHO HAS HAD THIS
VIRUS.
WHO IS IMMUNE GOING FORWARD
BECAUSE THEY HAVE IT AND THEY
HAVE ANTIBODIES TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES.
I AM GLAD YOU MADE THAT
DISTINCTION BECAUSE IT’S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE.
JUDGE JEANINE: ONCE YOU FIND OUT
YOU HAVE THE ANTIBODY, THE
ADMINISTRATION IS NOT LOOKING
FOR ANYONE TO ENGAGE IN ANY KIND
OF CARD CARRYING, OR SOMETHING
THAT SAYS I HAVE ANTIBODIES, I
CAN GO WHERE I WANT.
WE ARE TALK TALKING ABOUT
TRACING AND TRACKING, ARE WE?
>> IF YOU HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT
WITH SOMEONE WHO HAS THE
CORONAVIRUS, THAT’S WHAT THE
CONTACT TRACING COMPONENT OF
THIS IS.
JUDGE JEANINE: KAYLEIGH MCENANY,